le jour des morts n'aura lieu que mardi
mais déjà les squelettes et des crânes
géants se multiplient dans les rues de
mexico des oeuvres rempli de couleurs
mais non dénué de tristesse
puisque après une année de pandémie très
difficile au mexique il ya beaucoup de
morts a honoré en souvenir de ceux qui
sont partis mais qui reste dans nos
coeurs peut-on lire sur ce mur cet hôtel
est un mémorial en l'honneur des
victimes d'accueillir 19 ou memorial en
2000 est ce que toutes les familles qui
ont perdu un être cher pendant la
pandémie peuvent venir leur dire au
revoir à leur façon
les 14 mai du monument commémoratif sont
décorées avec des cases en argent qui
symbolisent les victimes selva perez
tenait à s'y recueillir
et les passages en 2020 il a perdu sa
grand mère son oncle et son grand-oncle
avec qui est habitée en fait la moitié
des gens sous son toit se mordre la
queue vide immense elle n'est pas seule
à venir pleurer ses morts
cet homme lui a apporté la photo de son
beau frère et de sa belle soeur décédée
ce printemps et seniors
signe que la situation s'améliore malgré
tout les restrictions sont plus souples
cette année et permet de se réunir en
plus grand nombre peut-être par couleur
cette fois ci en plus d'honorer les
morts promesses et femmes nous allons
célébrer la vie de ceux qui ont survécu
à la maladie
c'est que le mexique commence
tranquillement remonté la pente les
infections sont en baisse tout comme les
décès et plus de 80 % des adultes ont
reçu au moins une dose du vaccin ici
alexis andré bélisle radio canada
montréal